So today we discussed a learning method called learning by recording
cases. In learning by recording cases, we file away individual cases we
have encountered in the past in order to use them for future problem solving.
We talked about the nearest neighbor method as a way of finding the most similar
case to the current problem that we faced in the past. But in the real world,
this can often be very difficult. So we talked about using nearest neighbor to
find very complex similar cases to our current problem, such as our navigation
example. However, there are still a lot of limitations to this method.
Oftentimes, just executing a solution we've used in the past doesn't work.
And oftentimes, we have to store cases based on qualitative labels instead of
numeric labels. These weaknesses will be addressed
in our next lesson when we talk about case-based reasoning.
There we'll add adaptation and evaluation into our process, and
start to be able to use cases in a much more thorough and robust way.